[Gelächter]
0 40 jetzt bei mir angekommen
die regale
ich würde die wettersituation
beschreiben sind wir gerade wie geht ihr
sehr gut sind jetzt gerade was wir zu
tun wir nicht die jetzt eine bank pleite
gehen würde
[Musik]
sie laufen jetzt eben kurz zum bäcker
und wohl frühstück
ich muss einmal für mich laufen
[Musik]
was hast du holst agentur ist technisch
laser lukas wichtigsten laser luca okay
gut ist die situation hier punktet wegen
als welche mutter madonna trotzki
präsident butter was sagt man einem
engländer wenn hier gebracht werden
neben klopp die reden von dir ein
schloss wieder ein
ich hab dich hier im obst regal gefunden
es ist 12 uhr wir kaufen kasten
bitburger sie sieht mich im schaufenster
fragen linie
[Musik]
unsere mutter hat einfach so hart aus
dem geschäft das wir jetzt eine tonne
stehen lassen damit die weich wird hat
er muss ich sagen eine brücke kleines
bild sind genauso deine mario kart gilt
jetzt hier gerade alle zusammen bei
morgen früh strikt und werden jetzt in
unserer herberge vorbeigehen allgemein
seine freundin hier kurz bei den zuhause
alleine lassen und danach begeben wir
uns zum strand
ist es gerade später wir wollten
eigentlich nur unsere freundin alleine
lassen aber mein körper übels lang zum
hochladen
immer wird die internet situation hier
beschreiben
entscheiden muss angekommen öffnet der
bindig um sich noch die ganzen plötzlich
müssen also ich weiß nicht ob das yoga
sein soll oder nicht so ganz danach aus
wie neuerdings in yoga war somit das
dümmste was ich hier gesehen hat dass
youtube geben hier im urlaub ist
mittlerweile sorgen das wetter ja
einfach mit seinem laptop am strand
stehen sein video hochlädt und schneidet
das ist ein guter arbeitsplatz hier oder
tischen training am strand noch mal dass
du als öffentlichkeit tragen das sieht
man die auf jeden fall anderen
erfahrener sportler ist die jungs wollen
einfach einmal bis zum meer laufen aber
trübe bilanz hätte europa muss
in der tat sehr hoch
ganze 39 meine damen und herren wir
fuhren heute interview mit derzeitigen
situation blockade und dass diese scheiß
kamera übelsten abspecken ist mir tut
mir leid ich kann nichts für das ich
irgendwie univer kamera die auf
eventuell beheben kann oder wenn ihr
könnt ihr auch markt drin
die reden von mir weil ich bin ja so
stark wie sticks und frische art
wenn du deinen englischen freund fragt
ob wir leben oder sich natürlich auch
eine beliebte eigentlich mal geträumt
wenn jemand da steht ja du hast noch
gemeint wollte seine ernährung umstellen
er befindet sich auf den letzten metern
der tour de france musste nur noch um
die ecke gehen und jan ullrich nur der
post am garten achten erreicht platz jan
ullrich die vor ort gewonnen hat die
leipziger sind gerade eingetroffen
luca was machst du da hier komm ich
jetzt noch mal eine nahaufnahme falls
jetzt unbedingt noch mal sehen wollte
sie haben auf jeden fall gerade
grillfleisch eingekauft und werden jetzt
grillen
grillen versuchswagen ich mir die 14
juli gekauft hat einen nicht fontaine zu
konzentrieren also das baguette jetzt
meistens auch die teekanne jetzt fertig
gleich fleisch fleisch fleisch fleisch
fleisch gleich fleisch fleisch wir
stehen gerade wir mario kart schmeckt
wurzel nur eine sache deinen lieben nur
noch sagen wird und ein wort welches
wort werde
neben moritz steht keine flasche auf dem
boden neben christi kein flash auf dem
boden neben den zwei flaschen auf dem
boden ich glaube du bist wohl die größte
flasche die ihr wird ich gehe diesen weg
von der eben leute wären gerade
festgehalten dass crippen moritz einfach
gerade aussieht wie kemper achtet mal
drauf ich dadurch haben gerade ihr zelt
aufgeschlagen wie manni und sicherer
raum campingplatz gekommen und verstreut
versiert aufgebaut
[Musik]
ich würde sagen wir ärgernis superkurzen
beim spaghetti kochen macht so gut
egal ob koch ganz schön über man ja was
machen jubel häuser
schmeckt markiert man leicht mit unseren
kosten spaghetti probiert luca auf jeden
fall haben jetzt darauf werden wir gehen
nach hause und ich würde sagen durch der
gockel feiner würden wir uns sehr freuen
deswegen
[Musik]